well even at this 11th hour we'd hoped
that the prime minister would make good
on that commitment and bring world
leaders together to agree a joint
approach around an extension those
efforts have fallen short and the
painful reality is that there will be
many people britons and the afghans who
supported us over two decades who simply
aren't going to get out this is a really
really dark moment for many afghans
there are still hundreds in touch with
my office
at the moment who can't make it to the
airport and may now not be able to get
onto planes and it is a very shameful
moment for the government that after 18
months of warning and a failure to plan
we've now had this failure at the g7 and
we've got to confront the reality now
which is for every hour counts and that
everything every resource that can be
got to the front line to those brilliant
diplomats and staff and troops who are
trying to get people onto planes as
quickly and safely as possible every
effort must be made to support them the
hope was always there wasn't it that the
deadline would be extended we've all
seen the scenes outside kabul airport
but do you think the prime minister was
ever going to be able to convince joe
biden to extend that deadline
i think what we're seeing here is a
really shameful moment for the united
kingdom government this is the reality
of the global britain that he's created
this use of the term shameful why is it
shameful would anyone have been able to
get joe biden to change his mind
we've known since joe biden stood for
election that he was going to
uphold the commitment made by president
trump to withdraw troops we knew that
that would make the uk's position in
afghanistan militarily unsustainable
other countries put in place measures to
evacuate france for example starting
this process back in may we haven't done
it we made promises to those afghans who
supported us and many of them as the
defense secretary acknowledged will now
be left behind we should have been in a
position to bring those world leaders
together to try to convene some kind of
agreement france and germany both felt
it was important to try to persuade the
taliban to extend and yet the g7 has
been unable to reach that agreement and
the reality for many many afghans and
for britain and for our reputation
around the world is very stark indeed
we've got to show in the coming days
that we are serious that when we said we
were withdrawing troops but not walking
away from the people of afghanistan that
we meant it we need to put every effort
into keeping the land borders open by
working with regional partners and
supporting them with the refugee crisis
we need to agree a shared approach to
the taliban this is a very bleak moment
but we're in a new reality now and we've
got to confront it
how do we confront it um
the prime minister saying today that
they they've agreed on a joint approach
for the evacuation and indeed a road map
for engaging with the taliban
there's been a level of cooperation
going on between the united kingdom
our troops and our allies over the last
few weeks which has been you know an
incredibly proud moment for those troops
who were who'd flown back into kabul and
have been working hand-in-hand with
other countries to make sure that they
can get as many people onto planes as
possible and the prime minister
suggested today that that cooperation
would continue there are other things
that we could do i learned today about a
number of cases for example involving
children their parents are eligible
therefore they're eligible to get on
those flights but they can't because
they haven't got passport applications
processed surely it must be possible to
drop some of those bureaucratic
requirements where we know that it's
safe that there's no threat to the uk so
that we can get people out very quickly
and then we need to agree a shared
approach the prime minister hinted for
example at the leverage that we have in
relation to the taliban and protecting
those gains that we've fought for over
the last 20 years the g7 represents a
third of the world's economy there are
billions of dollars in assets that were
held by the afghan government in western
bank accounts nine billion of them in
the u.s alone we ought to be using that
leverage in order to uphold human rights
and support those people who will be
left behind and are very very worried
about what the future holds right now